well this is the press preview a first
look at what's on the front pages
as they reaches here at sky center so
let's see what's in those headlines
with the broadcaster and former mp anna
subri in the mail on sunday commentator
dan hodges they're going to be with us
right through until midnight uh before
we have a chat
it is good to see you both by the way
let's just have a look at those front
pages for you we'll start with the
telegraph
it reports that the government intends
to allow double vaccinated u.s and eu
citizens
to travel into the uk without
restriction
from august the 16th the guardian leads
on tomorrow's expected announcement on a
quarantine waiver for double-jabbed u.s
and eu arrivals
and the times also leading on borders
and how they could open up for the
double vaccinated
as early as next week it says whereas
the express leads with the suggestion
the bulk of the pandemic could be behind
us by october
the metro tells us the story of 34 year
old matthew keenan who'd refused the
covid vaccine before contracting the
virus
and later told his doctors that he
wished he'd had the jab
he died yesterday the financial times
carries a warning from the international
monetary fund that the limited access
that developing nations have to vaccines
is going to hinder any global economic
recovery
and the mail has spoken to an unnamed
senior minister who describes the
pandemic as being
all over bar the shouting
so let's talk through some of those with
anna and dan it is good to see you both
let's kick
off with um that comment in the mail
should we
that the this pandemic is all over by
the shouting anna
well i wish it was i i mean i i'm
with the prime minister perhaps for once
by saying i think we've got to be really
cautious about this i mean you can't
deny that the number of infection the
infection rate is going down
deaths of course are going up but the
male is reporting as you can see
that a senior unnamed minister no
surprise
claims it's all over father shouting
well it isn't all over
uh and i still think we have to be very
cautious
uh especially coming into september when
the schools go back so i think
caution let's wait and see wish it were
all over by the shouting but i think
we've got a bit of a way to go yeah and
sorry the other thing is of course is
that we could be very careful with these
messages because we still want people to
get either their second vaccination
or to go and get both that includes
obviously the first one
to go out and get that vaccination so
it's really important that the messaging
is right here and i don't think the mail
helps
i mean it's extraordinary dan isn't it
that a senior minister would say this
when the prime minister himself is busy
telling us that we
you know we still need to apply a great
deal of caution
yes on one level but on another level
let's let's think about where we are i
mean last week
the government announced that we were
formally gonna make
the final step out of lockdown
um obviously if you remember
for weeks ministers including the prime
minister were saying
we wouldn't take that final step unless
the data supported that move
obviously there was some some quite
scary looking figures in terms of
infections
but in terms of hospitalizations and and
death rates obviously
any death is tragic but in terms of
hospitalizations and death rates
they were well within the parameters
that ministers themselves had set
when they set out the road map and
frankly i you know and i wrote about
this a couple of weeks ago i i don't
actually understand
why we had this sudden
sort of sort of crisis of confidence
from from boris just to the point
that that we unlocked that the reality
is
as i said we you know we were given a
road map by the government the
government's followed it the plan seems
to have worked
crucially we were all told
that if if people continued to get
vaccinated particularly in those
those most vulnerable groups the the
over 50s
then that was the route out of this
crisis we have very high levels of
vaccination amongst those groups
and i think whilst you know i agree with
that we you know obviously there needs
to be a degree of caution
i do also think now that we need to
start to move
beyond this sense of national crisis
that we've all been living under for the
last 18 months
we all know you know if if god forbid
another variant comes sweeping along
that will that will change the dynamic
but but i do
think now we have to stop living as i
say under this
mood of perpetual crisis and sort of
perpetual foreboding
um that's that that this blanket that's
been sitting across the nation for the
last 18 months because i just don't
think it's sustainable
uh meanwhile anna i mean the metro is
is focusing on on the case of one
particular
vaccine skeptic i mean which which
hammers home the message
pretty hard as hard as you can really
just how important it is
absolutely i mean this young man
young i think we'd all agree he's what
in his in his 30s
matthew matthew keenan he was a skeptic
yeah he was 34
he was a skeptic so he didn't get jabbed
he then got covered
he was so ill he went into hospital he
went into intensive care there's a
photograph as you can see on the front
page of the metro
of him with getting oxygen and he said
to his doctors
you know i wish i had got jabbed because
he had hit him as we know it can
yes it's rare but it can still affect
even young people like him right matthew
and of course it's killed him so you
know i still think we should be cautious
um and i think you know that message of
go and get a jab
grab a jab is absolutely critical
especially in the young
because it will spread and you know
in crude terms that's what herd immunity
is all about when you run out of hosts
you run out of bodies
so if we all get jab and we will hasten
that day
yeah yeah let's have a look at the
telegraph dan can we because this
actually is a really important move
isn't it if we're expecting this
announcement tomorrow about
who can come into the uk without having
to quarantine and
and potentially we're told the uk uh
the uk government is going to allow us
and
eu citizens in
yeah and again that's part of what i was
i i was just talking about i mean in
terms of the policy decision
decisions that are being taken they're
all moving in one direction and i think
what i think part of the problem we've
had over the last couple of weeks
is that the policy decisions we've been
getting from the government and the
rhetoric
we've been getting from the government
have been completely divergent so on the
one hand we've been saying you know
we're lifting restrictions on social
distancing you can go back
to pubs you can go back to clubs you can
go back to work etc but but but but but
but don't
you know as effectively been the message
um
and i do think that i think that's
confused people i think that scared
people
and i think worst of all that has
undermined confidence
in the messaging that we've been getting
from ministers and from
the medical experts and i think this
move that's being outlined in the papers
tomorrow again
moves us you know underlines the fact
that certainly as far as ministers are
concerned we are now
given all the caveats that we we've
talked about and the need that everybody
needs to make sure
they're offered a vaccine they get a
vaccine that we are now
moving towards the end of this crisis
and i think
that is something that we should embrace
rather than you know continue to try and
create
a a mood of doom and a mood of crisis
it does seem extraordinary anna that you
know if you've had you you you know your
two fives of vaccines or astrazeneca
vaccines over here go to i don't know
spain for a holiday you can just come
back
if you've had them in spain you can't
you've got to come back and quarantine
at the moment it's a bit odd isn't it
no that just does not make sense at all
and of course it'll work both ways
because
you know we don't what we don't want is
if we're opening up letting people in
here
um then we want to be in a position
whereby you know our vaccines are also
accepted and seen from what they are i
think one of the things that's going to
happen
is you know what is the government going
to do about the
double jabbers or us double jabbers
because that is now almost
what is the majority um are we are we
going to insist on some sort of
passport to prove that you have had
those two vaccines
or effectively is the government going
to just say you know what nobody's going
to have to prove anything
because we know what the stats tell us
and
my only caution with that is that those
people who i still think should go and
get second jab
or actually get the whole thing they
need to go and do it and what we don't
want is people think oh well i don't
need to do it now because you know
freedom day genuinely is about to dawn
uh
and the crisis is over and um therefore
i won't go and get my jabs and we do
need to get everybody jabbed up
because the other thing is is that we're
going to get into a period i suspect
of having booster jabs and then we're
going to have the flu jab
as well and they'll probably put them
together so if you're like we need to
sort of instill in people this
is this this idea that you know getting
vaccinated
is now probably going to be something
that we will all have to do for the
foreseeable future so we don't want to
break that habit
by people thinking oh that's it it's all
over now you know this thing is not
going away we're just learning to live
with it
yeah i mean what directing down to the
idea of of the fact we are going to have
to have some sort of
vaccination certification or passports
however you want to phrase it
well as someone who's been been double
jab myself i mean i had i
instinctively have some sympathy with
what anna's saying but
but there's an important point i think
that we have to we have to remember here
you know anna was sitting there saying
you know we've all got to get jabbed
you know that wasn't the message several
months ago
the message was very clear the people
who had to get
jabbed and get double jabbed were those
who were in the most vulnerable
groups 80 plus 70 plus 60 plus 50 plus
we were specifically told that once we
got to that point and once we got to
that levels of vaccination
then basically we had this thing be
nobody was wrong
wandering around three or four months
ago saying the twit
if if the 20 year olds don't get
vaccinated we're all doomed
so i whilst i you know i i instinctively
you know appreciate we all have to do it
i
i think we have got to be slightly
careful
about suddenly changing the narrative
and changing
the instructions i mean let me just
because
we're very out of time i just i just
want anna to comment on that because i
mean
are you aware of a narrative change anna
no i i sorry i thought that it was
always going to be the case that we
would do it in stages
the most vulnerable obviously would get
vaccinated and then we would go down the
the various age groups and you know
actually the debate has been whether or
not
um children over the age of 12 should
get it so i
i don't think the narratives changed at
all and actually i have to say i've been
doing a bit of volunteering and one of
the things that i notice amongst the
youngsters is they're getting
vaccinated not so much for themselves
but actually for the likes of
people like me who are over 60 and
happen to be asthmatic they understand
the need
and to stop the spread of the infection
to build up this immunity across the
whole of society
as the most important way to see off
this um this awful thing
so let's talk olympics should we because
we've got an awful lot to celebrate i
think if we look at the
the top of the metro we can see tom dean
he beat covert twice has now got his
olympic gold we've got a
1-2 in the swimming freestyle 200 meters
i mean
we've finally got underway on our room
we're belting it
it's brilliant isn't it it's the boost
we all need and i just think it's great
i love watching it
i'm not going to say i can stay up as
late as i know you have to but no
i mean these these are a superb uh
team of very young athletes no doubt
inspired
as i think as you were reporting earlier
on in news bulletins by
um our successors and our hosting of the
london games
uh and it's an absolute joy to behold
the only the only sorrow of it all
is that of course their families can't
be with them but hell haven't we enjoyed
watching the videos of
uh tom dean's family all celebrating his
great success so uh
yeah just what we need it's great yeah
what do you writing down it is a it is a
it's kind of a shot in the arm for all
of us isn't it
well you know what i'm going to be
perfectly honest here i was just about
to lie my ass off there and completely
agree with anna i've got to be honest
i haven't watched any i've gotta be
completely honest
i really just haven't been able to get
into this olympics i don't know what it
is
i don't know i mean i got completely
caught up in the euros
uh it may be covered it may be it just
it just caught up i could sit here i
could lie to you and say i've been
sitting up at three in the morning
cheering on the synchronized swimming
and the dressage
i've got to be honest i haven't really
got into it you know i hope i will maybe
maybe you'll inspire me too now but up
until dan you've got to watch the surf
it's not you've got to watch this
you've got the sun i even watched it i
didn't even know there was
a surfing thing yeah and the guy that
won it actually broke his board you
might have thought he would have broken
his leg but he didn't he broke his board
even i mean i was right i didn't care
what country they are yeah
cheering them in your mouth it was
brilliant yeah i look i think there's a
lot there's a lot to be said for i know
what you mean down there some of the
atmosphere and things just isn't
there at the moment but when we know
something our best
olympic start ever we're doing something
right
which is really good to know